I found out I have a diagnosis of
bipolar disorder
I'm gonna be honest I didn't want to go
to a mental health hospital but I didn't
want to be
trapped in myself in my mind anymore
I thought my life was over I was like
this is how I'm going to be forever
Nina Gomez her friends and family get
emotional we're calling her
hospitalization and diagnosis with
bipolar disorder she was in recovery
herself but she wanted really to help
other people and that meant having to
share some of the private moments of her
life she says I want you to film this
film The Pain back in 2016 Selena made
headlines when her Revival tour was
abruptly canceled after 55 performances
and she was hospitalized to focus on her
mental health to be sharing something
honest and saying hey I'm taking a break
because I need it I'm being honest and I
think that's just who I am now fans get
a little more insight into what really
went down in her new Apple TV plus
documentary my mind and me
at one point she's like I don't want to
be alive right now and it was one of
those moments where you looked in her
eyes and there's nothing there you're
like okay like this needs to end like we
need to go home I just remember it being
very chaotic and she was hearing all of
these voices they just kept getting
louder and louder and louder that
triggered some sort of psychotic break I
was scared she was gonna die I feel like
it is it's a time capsule of a period of
my life where I look back and I actually
feel bad for my that version of myself
and I I think that it was good for me to
see how I was responding to my body the
way I was acting the way it was so
irrational at moment and I think it was
really healing for me to see that and
get it out Sal's mom Mandy teepe says
that at the time her daughter wasn't
speaking to her so she found out about
cell's hospitalization through a media
outlet that reached out for comment
their media is constantly saying
outrageous things to her talk about
voices in your head you know she had
voices in her had but some of those
voices were coming from the outside in
it and following her bipolar diagnosis
Selena admits she has she had a lot of
regret about the
saying they never gave up on her even
when so many times they probably should
have all that Echoes what Selena told
E.T about her family's tight Bond back
in 2009 in the early stages of her
career I always say in this business you
get told a lot of things that you
shouldn't be told like yes you're this
yes you're perfect and my mom's there to
tell me no my family calls me whenever
they see something that they're not
really proud of so then they're like
um what's going on and that keeps me
that keeps me on the ground too now
Selena says she needed to go through all
that to be who she is today
she's not just an advocate for mental
health she's not just a pop star she is
also a woman dealing daily with her own
kind of challenges and trying to be a
good person through all of it
[Music]